et c'est dans ce contexte de tensions
autour de la police que les conclusions
du rapport d'expertisé sur la mort de
zineb redouane ont été rendues souvenez
vous elle c'était en décembre 2018 cette
femme algérienne a été tué à présent tir
de grenade lacrymogène alors qu'elle
fermait les fenêtres de son appartement
durant une manifestation des gilets
jaunes à marseille
et selon une expertise balistique
révélée par le monde et le parisien
le policier auteur du tir a bien
respecté les règles d'utilisation son
arme selon les conclusions du rapport la
mort de zineb red one serait donc
accidentelle pour en parler
son fils samir redouane est avec nous en
direct sur rt france samir redouane
merci d'être avec nous cet après midi en
direct sur rt france alors quelle a été
votre première réaction quand vous avez
eu les conclusions du rapport d
expertise
expliquant que la mort de votre mère est
accidentelle bonjour et vous remercie
pour l'intérêt que vous portez pour
affaires de ma mère
voilà
jésus comme tous les citoyens qu'un peu
que la justice a disculpé des policiers
dans ma sphère du tir nous moi et toute
la famille on était vraiment déçu
d'apprendre cela du moment que encore
après une année et demie on s'attendait
à mieux
dans l' enquête vous vous attendiez à
mieux dans l' enquête c'est à dire vous
n'avez pas confiance dans cette
expertise que ou alors qu'ils vous
remettez en cause aujourd'hui la réunion
et demie d'attentes
je crois que la justice n'a pas fait
bien son travail
non nous on n'en a pas voulu faire
agrandir des choses on attend dé la
justice
on faisait confiance à la justice
française mais maintenant le rat avec la
crise qui peut disent qu'ils peuvent
passer en de la police je vois que les
choses sont revenues à la case départ
est ce que vous vous avez des éléments
sur ce qui s'est passé qui vous
interroge encore oui bien sûr j'ai des
éléments on avait témoigné sur marseille
il y avait deux policiers de qu'ils
étaient stationnés devant devant
l'immeuble bois habité ma mère ma mère
d'abord avant de mourir on a parlé avec
elle elle nous a nous a dit que que le
policier visé directement vous voyez
elle habitait dans le quatrième étage
c'était c'était vraiment loin pour être
un accident
qu'est ce que vous attendez dorénavant
de la justice bon maintenant
vraiment je je suis parce que je suis
pas je suis déçu je m'attendais pas à ça
je croyais que la justice française va
faire convenable
non sans travail nous on demandait rien
du tout on demander que justice soit
faite seulement on est depuis une année
et demi qu'on est traumatisée on est
rené pas on n'a pas fait mon deuil
notre des plus tôt pour conclure alors
comment en quelques mois est ce que vous
comptez engager des suites est ce qu'on
demande en peut-être par exemple je sais
pas une une expertise indépendante
oui avec notre avocat
on va voir comment on va faire de notre
ombre a demandé contre expertise de
suite on va se faire de toute façon on
va pas baisser les bras
oh non on fera tout pour avoir un
justice un merci beaucoup samir redouane
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le fils de zineb
redouane